Let's look at what the forward Euler method does to this equation.
X after the first step will be the initial value of x plus the time step
times the rate of change at the initial time plus the rate of change at times 0.
What's the rate of change at times 0? It's -kx(0).
We can factor out x or 0 and end up with this expression.
That's the result after the first times step.
The initial value gets multiplied by 1 minus step size times the constant that appears in the test equation.
Now, let's do the second step--it's x at the end of the previous step
plus h times the rate of change at that time or actually our estimate of that rate of change
at that time which would be -kx(h), again we can factor out and we can plug in the value of x(h)
from the first step, so we end up with (1-hk) times now x(h),
(1-hk) x(0) which is if we combine these two, (1-hk)² x(0)
and you see how this is going to proceed if you go to (3h), this will become (4h)^4 and so on.
The question was whether or not x is going to approach 0.
This boils down to whether or not (1-hk)ⁿ approaches 0 as n times to infinity.
So what happens to the nth power of (1-hk), we are interested in how large h the step size can be?
If the step size h gets large, the expression inside the parenthesis
becomes negative, we are subtracting from 1.
If we are subtracting more than 1, the inner term here gets negative.
So the question here is what happens to powers of negative numbers to some huge power.
As an example, what happens if the inner expression equals -2
and we take the 1st, 2nd, 3rd, 4th and so on power.
(-2)¹ is -2. (-2)² is 4. (-2)³ is -8. (-2)⁴ is 16 and so on which means that this expression,
the nth power would explode and this is precisely not what we want for a stable solution.
So let's try a different number. So what would happen if the inner expression was -0.9,
and we took powers of (-0.9). (-0.9)¹ is 0.9. (-0.9)² is 0.81. (-0.9)³ is -0.723. (-0.9)⁴ is 0.6561.
Each time, we are losing 10% in magnitude but you see that the sign keeps changing,
minus, plus, minus, plus, so this indeed decays to 0 but in a strange fashion. It oscillates.
You may remember this behavior from the SEIR model that we simulated before.
If this expression would equal -0.99, it would still see decay with this sort of oscillation.
If it would equal -0.999, this would still work but become very, very slow.
So the threshold would be that (1-hk) is in the expression equals -1.
The threshold, it's 2/k. So the condition is h is smaller than 2/k for this power to decay to 0
and for the forward Euler method to be stable.